all of us have seen what a number line
is it has a zero in the center positive
values at equal intervals on the right
which go on forever and negative values
at equal intervals on the left a number
on the right of a number will always be
greater and that on the left will always
be smaller we can easily give any number
on this line and identity if the point
lies here we can say that it is one unit
to the right of zero this point for
example is two units to the left of zero
but what if we have a point here how do
we give point a and identity to give
such points an identity we draw another
line perpendicular to this one we have
positive values above zero and negative
values under it or let equal intervals
these two lines are called the axes the
horizontal line is called the x axis and
the vertical one is called the y axis
now can we give this point an identity
with the help of the axis of course we
can it is two units away from the y axis
and three units away from the x axis two
units away from the Y and three away
from the X its identity would be 2 comma
3 in a fancy way they are called the
coordinates of point a two is the x
coordinate while three is the y
coordinate can we write the y coordinate
first and then DX nope we cannot the x
coordinate has to be written first why
don't you try writing the coordinates of
point B it is one unit away from the y
axis and three units away from the x
axis but wait three units below the x
axis so the coordinates will be 1 comma
minus 3
so that's how we give points on the
plane some identity x-coordinate
followed by the y-coordinate these two
axes divide the plane into four regions
this one this one this one and this one
they are called quadrants this region
where the X as well as the Y values are
positive is called the first quadrant
the region to the left of it is called
the second quadrant Y positive and X
negative this is the third and this is
the fourth quadrant it goes
counterclockwise one two three and four
this plane that you see is called the
coordinate plane and we will be looking
at more of it in the coming sessions